m
le monde agricole sort de ces chants le
temps d'une journée le conseil
départemental poursuit sa concertation
avec le monde agricole
seule compétente dans le domaine la
collectivité définit les orientations
pour 2014 2020 l'europe investit quant à
385 millions d'euros pour l'agriculture
réunionnaise il faut qu'on se saisissent
de cette opportunité là pour faire
avancer les filières après le vote par
l'union européenne du fonds européen
agricole pour le développement rural
feader la collectivité est en charge de
sa mise en place locale non agricoles
aujourd'hui attendait
cette journée pour pouvoir avoir une
vision
de notre agriculture
pour la fin d'année pour le début
d'année prochaine c'est un nouveau
programme qu'il est mort et il fallait
qu'on ait ce calendrier
si on fait des étapes comme ça à chaque
fois bon on peut que qu'approuver la
méthode
maintenant c'est l'avenir qui nous dira
ce qu'il en tire offert mesure des
étapes dans la salle toutes les forces
en présence du monde agricole partage
échange sur les points d'étape de ce
programme pour les sept prochaines
années était de savoir est-ce qu'on a
pris en considération toutes les
demandes toutes les spécificités qu'on
avait demandé à l'époque pour voir si on
n'a rien oublié de poser les questions
sur ce qui il revient
qui peut avoir changé au dernier moment
et puis savoir surtout le calendrier
d'application puisque depuis un an
maintenant on n'a fait aucune
installation on n'a mis en place aucun
projet ça nous permet de rassurer la le
suivi des nos éleveurs pour mémoire nous
sur les reçus à la sica révia c'est
quand même 320 éleveurs qui qui doivent
bénéficier de 50 et 51 encadrement
technique pardon la règle l'exigent
après la validation du feader par les
instances européennes
la prochaine étape obligatoire du pdr
air ainsi que le comité national et
local de suivi permettront de libérer
les fonds européens tant attendu par le
monde agricole
on est dans un pensée globale on peut
pas penser à celui qui pense que non il
se met à lui seul une balle dans le pied
je crois qu'on a la nécessité
aujourd'hui d'avoir cette approche de
cette de jouer collectif comme on dit
souvent approche globale partir du local
mais avoir une approche globale de la
situation et dans cette approche globale
il ya le monde agricole un uniforme
il ya aussi les acteurs les acteurs qui
interviennent notamment dans les
territoires ruraux et dans les hauts de
la réunion les hauts de la réunion c'est
un sans doute un nouveau projet à bâtir
une vision a partagé avec la région avec
les opci avec les communes qui sont les
acteurs locaux raccorder cadre
réglementaire et actions de terrain et
le défi de ces prochains mois
et une fois de plus la concertation et
une communication partager ce relais clé
du succès